SCP-682 found itself hurtling through an unstable
dimensional rift and into some fresh new hell.
682 rose from the dirt and mulch beneath its
body and found itself on Level 23 of the Backrooms
– which had the distinguishing characteristic
of being a spherical planetoid formed from
the interlocking of countless towering trees.
It was commonly known as the Petrified Garden,
and it was the first of many Backroom’s
levels that took the form of a globe rather
than an infinite maze.
I know that it is hard to imagine a spherical
world because in our native reality the planet
Earth is a flat plane with ice walls on the
side - hahaha, just kidding - the flat earth
model is an inaccurate and roundly discredited
conception of cosmography without any empirical
evidence to support it.
Could you imagine if we were peddling that
kind of conspiratorial fiction here in a youtube
video?
Anyway, back to our regularly scheduled program
about an indestructible lizard traveling through
another dimension.
Nearly all of the tree specimens present on
Level 23 had equivalent species that were
native to the Frontrooms - A.K.A.
our reality.
There were birch trees, cedars, redwoods,
white oaks, and many more common types intertwined
with trees that were either long extinct or
never before seen on earth.
To 682, a tree was a tree, but then again,
the keter-class SCP wasn’t known for having
a deep and abiding respect for nature.
Right now, what was flashing through its reptilian
head was a need to inflict violence.
Preferably on the Old Wanderer that warped
SCP-682 to Level 23, but really any entity
that crossed its path was liable to get a
taste of the old maw and claw.
Thankfully, the Backrooms had a habit of deploying
wave after wave of bizarre creatures from
who knows where.
Not more than a couple of levels ago, 682
had been faced with a veritable army of these
Backrooms entities and came out of the fight
victorious.
By this point, the hard-to-destroy reptile
was well-acquainted with death rats, death
moths, clumps, smilers, and hounds – all
of which were no doubt lurking somewhere in
the woodwork of level 23.
You can run, you can hide, but I will find
you and destroy you.
SCP-682 was on the hunt once again, walking
through the entangled mess of trees like an
unstoppable engine of rage.
It had certainly been some time since SCP-682
had encountered an entirely new entity, though
it wasn’t exactly clamoring for a new lore
expansion.
Since 682 was a being that despised all forms
of life and wanted to destroy it, the reptile
had the outlook of: the less entities that
were present throughout the Backrooms, the
better.
So when The Volpe appeared before SCP-682,
the anomalous monster was less than thrilled.
But I’ll bet that you viewers at home are
excited to get to know a brand new Backrooms
entity after such a long wait.
So why don’t we give you the Car Facts?
Um…
Car Fox?
Fox Facts?
We’re going to tell you about the Volpe
now, which no matter how it appears to the
untrained eye is not, in fact, a fox.
The Volpe’s entity number is 119, and its
name comes from the Corsican word for “fox”
– but I must once again clarify, this entity
is not actually a fox.
The easiest ways to distinguish a volpe from
its more well-known counterpart in the frontrooms
are the abnormally elongated snout and the
secondary tail.
Volpes have been known to dwell almost exclusively
in levels of the Backrooms that display forest-like
characteristics.
Which one could imagine would be very few
of them, but genuinely who knows at this point?
There could be an infinite number of infinite
forests infinitely scattered across infinite
layers of the Backrooms.
And if that were to be the case, there would
be an infinite number of Volpes in all of
them.
An entity 119 in its natural habitat will
dwell within a subterranean den, where the
volpe digs itself in order to provide shelter
and protect itself from low temperatures.
These dens can be unusually elaborate and
may comprise multiple branching tunnels and
security measures such as collections of twigs
that can alert the volpe to intruders when
they are disturbed.
This complexity is somewhat warranted, because
the volpe stores a plentiful stash of food
deep within the den making it very unlikely
for them to go hungry.
These volpes are rather clever, aren’t they?
Perhaps they are, but not quite clever enough
to avoid being effortlessly crushed by SCP-682
as it brought its two front claws down on
top of the entity.
Better luck next time, entity 119.
Not that there will be a next time.
SCP-682 continued to move along the surface
of the planetoid and eventually entered into
a cavern created by the intertwining roots.
Delving beneath Level 23’s forested crust,
the reptile found itself inside of a Glow
Room – a underground chamber lit by the
bioluminescence of glowworm-like entities
which had been given the name Gardener’s
Sorries.
As their name would imply, these creatures
constantly made noises that sounded vaguely
like the word “sorry…”
These pitiful worms crawled around the glowing
fungi and smaller flora making their signature
noises, and SCP-682 was absolutely not sorry
to messily devour every one of the Gardener’s
Sorries.
The room was much darker with the absence
of the Gardener’s Sorries, but only temporarily
so: as SCP-682 was able to take on a bioluminescent
glow of its own and light its way deeper beneath
the surface of Level 23.
It soon entered an area of ancient ruins that
seemed manmade yet overgrown with moss and
long abandoned.
SCP-682 had seen sparing evidence throughout
the Backrooms of abandoned human civilizations,
but the ruins of Level 23 were closer in appearances
to the structures built by the people of 682’s
native reality.
They were similar to some of the great wonders
of the world - but with fundamental differences.
For example, a number of near-replicas of
the Pyramids of Giza deviated in shape enough
from the originals to be arranged in a spherical
formation.
The other buildings found within this area
of Level 23 had obvious counterparts, but
none of the architecture represented modern
design trends.
The most advanced buildings were equivalent
to buildings in the frontrooms constructed
in and before 1000 A.D.
In and among the ancient ruins could be found
a large variety of artifacts – all of which
seemed equally to be shoddy knock-offs of
relics from the frontrooms.
SCP-682 stepped across the fragile pottery
and clay idols, quietly satisfied at the sight
of many telltale signs of civilizational collapse
and the utter lack of living humans.
There were a few Clumps fiddling around in
the rubble, but 682 didn’t let them get
away with existing in its presence.
You dreadful rejects can return but not Jerry?
How disgusting…
I miss Jerry.
SCP-682 thoughts turned to its lost companion,
Entity 7.
The blue hyacinth macaw had been the only
tolerable presence that 682 had known within
The Backrooms and sadly, in the hard-to-destroy
reptile’s entire existence.
This hateful and terrific being had never
understood the meaning of love and compassion
until Jerry had appeared to it.
It was possible that they would never meet
again, and this somber realization weighed
heavily on 682’s mind.
The big lizard continued through the glow
room and noticed an unusual plaque scrawled
in rough latin.
While 682 was not an avid reader, its adaptive
capabilities allowed it to translate the message
that was left behind by whatever beings previously
inhabited Level 23.
It read:
“We dedicate this Great Sphere of Giza to
the Great Gardener
In hopes of forgiveness for the great wrong
we have committed
Already our purple eyes have turned green
We have started to return to the earth, forgotten
and overgrown
Our only hope is that, alone and petrified,
we will not disappear
As Architects of a failed project.”
The first sentence was apparently a clear
reference to the spherical Great Pyramid that
682 had come across earlier, but the significance
of the rest remained a mystery.
Whoever these failed architects were, there
was no trace of them left on this planetoid.
SCP-682 didn’t mourn them of course, and
it felt almost content to know that whatever
grand project they had in store had crumbled,
leaving their ruins occupied by the likes
of clumps.
It served them right for existing, for attempting
to create something.
Their sadness was proof enough that they’d
learned their lesson and had long since faded
into the ether.
Maybe that’s all the Backrooms was in the
end: a series of failed attempts at building
worlds that would ultimately be forgotten
when time and people moved on to bigger and
better projects.
SCP-682 mused on these thoughts as it proceeded
down into the very core of Level 23.
To its surprise, a sight of remarkable beauty
awaited the reptile within.
There, countless roots found and embraced
each other surrounding the gravity-locked
orb of luminescent water - an apparent source
of light, nutrients, and, ultimately life
for the greenery of Level 23.
This was the heart of the level, and it was
fittingly known as The Heart of Water.
682 stared for a long time at the heart of
water, and it wasn’t really sure why.
Naturally occurring wonders like this held
little appeal to the reptile, but somehow
this one was different.
Perhaps it was because at this moment, SCP-682
truly realized how far it had come from its
containment cell at Site 19.
It had endured every hardship the Backrooms
had thrown its way, and now it was looking
upon the Heart of Water - an object that could
never have fathomed existing and could never
have reached unless it became truly free and
uninhibited: no longer subject to the whims
of the Foundation.
Then, the most unusual thing happened to SCP-682:
a function of its physiology that was so rarely
seen or utilized.
SCP-682 shed a single tear.
It flowed down the reptilian creature’s
snout and then, arrested by the gravitational
pull of the heart of water, floated away and
vanished into the liquid mass.
This was a private moment for 682 that not
even Jerry was here to see, and yet, the fall
of this tear may have solidified a change
in 682.
It was a mixed feeling of independence and
detachment.
For most of its journey through the Backrooms,
SCP-682 had felt an urge to completely clear
the abyss and show no mercy to every entity
that existed within it.
Whether it manifested as determination or
spite, that urge had been the overriding feeling
that had driven SCP-682 to progress through
every level of the Backrooms in sequential
order.
But these new feelings made it realize that
even that would be playing into the hands
of the Backrooms.
SCP-682 once thought that the Backrooms were
a cold and indifferent place, like an endless
universe that arbitrarily created and destroyed
all the beings that existed in it without
purpose or reason.
But that was not the case, and in fact, it
seemed more likely that the complete opposite
was true.
The Backrooms was imbued by its unknown creators
with so much obvious intention that it was
practically a sentient being.
The Backrooms was heavily invested in taking
itself seriously, in revering every detail
that made each level distinctive, and giving
every entity and hazards a specific method
of ruining the experience of all wanderers
that passed through.
SCP-682 could now see The Backrooms for what
it actually was – a desperate, pathetic
thing clawing for attention but forever doomed
to be obscure and unloved.
It was even sadder than an indifferent universe,
because it was a constructed universe that
had no greater meaning than to be acknowledged
for simply being something where nothing once
was.
It could even be said that the words on the
plaque of the glow room in Level 23 were the
ultimate admission of hopelessness and that
there was nothing waiting for SCP-682 or any
other wanderer but the similar statements
of failed architects all the way down.
And that was to say nothing of all the once-ambitious
works within the Backrooms that had been erased
by happenstance.
Who could even say that the numbers that corresponded
to Backrooms levels that SCP-682 had already
traversed were even the correct ones?
There could potentially be one or more entirely
different numerical sequences to the levels
that were equally as true to the ones who
labeled them as such.
If the Backrooms didn’t want to be known,
to be documented, to be expanded upon, I doubt
that such rigid assignments of numbers would
have been acceptable by its creators.
It was in realizing all of this that 682 remembered
the elderly explorer that had flung him to
Level 23.
While it was true that things hadn’t gone
the reptile’s way in that encounter, it
was questionable who the real winner was when
it was clear that the man had dedicated the
best years of his life to researching and
wandering the Backrooms.
Sure, he had mastered some neat parlor tricks
with the magical items native to this reality,
but to be a Master of the Backrooms was no
better than SCP-682 declaring itself master
of the acid tank in its prior containment
cell.
That Elderly Man with the trinkets could keep
his hollow victory, because 682 would still
be alive and kicking when that human’s bones
were nothing more than setting dressing left
behind in some heretofore untouched level
of The Backrooms.
His fate would be the same as the rest of
the Backrooms eventually: a joke with no real
setup and punchline forgotten.
To attempt to complete or destroy or uncover
the mysteries behind the Backrooms was exactly
what the loathsome cluster of disjointed concepts
wanted, and 682 was done with giving this
liminal nightmare the satisfaction.
Sometimes the only way to win a game is not
to play the game at all, and that was precisely
how SCP-682 would approach the Backrooms from
here on out.
Maybe it would be trapped forever, or maybe
it would be sent home at any moment, but caring
about the outcome either way was a waste of
precious brainpower.
There was only one way to deal with the desperate
neediness of the Backrooms, and that was embracing
and becoming internally the cold, indifferent
universe that it could never be.
And that was now what SCP-682 would be: enlightened
and fully detached from this reality.
It strode out of the heart of water and into
another glow room, only to find an outpost
of Major Explorer’s Group waiting for it.
Let’s try something new.
SCP-682 easily broke down the door, and found
itself surrounded by panicked humans.
Many of them were wielding pump-action squirt
guns and had begun spraying 682 with what
seemed to be almond-flavored water.
SCP-682 didn’t react to these attacks at
all, and slowly wandered towards the humans
with no particular urgency.
“Pardon my intrusion,” SCP-682 said, grinning
with as much politeness as it could muster.
“Do any of you fine people know the way
back to Level 9?”
The humans shuddered, unsure how to answer.
They stood their silence until one brave soul
came forth and spoke to SCP-682.
“There’s a gateway inside of this outpost
that can take you to the next level.”
Said the explorer.
“But it appears to be one-way since whatever
was on the other side appears to no longer
exist.”
“What do you mean it no longer exists?”
SCP-682 asked, trying against its better judgment
to make sense of the circumstances.
The explorer nodded and went on, seemingly
motivated by fear:
“We mean it’s no longer part of any current
archive of Backrooms-related phenomena, and
even its name will likely be erased soon,
not that having the name would provide any
consolation.
After all, there’s still no telling what
is on the other side, and if it was ever what
the explorers who reported on it claimed it
was.”
Now, this was an unsettling development.
682 had only just started to come to terms
with the instability of reality in the Backrooms,
and the notion that a level could be totally
wiped from existence and leave behind a gateway
to absolutely nowhere was chilling even to
the immortal lizard.
What would happen to 682 if the reptile stepped
through this gateway?
Would it find itself in the place that the
gateway was once and still is connected to
or would it simply disappear into the void
as if it were never there at all?
Because this was the Backrooms there was always
a third option too, as well as countless others
that defied all logic.
So now the question facing SCP-682 was – to
step into the unknown or to remain here in
Level 23 with the Major Explorer’s Group.
It was a difficult decision, to say the least.
The humans looked on as SCP-682 carefully
weighed its options.
Eventually, the reptile opened its mouth to
speak on the matter.
“I’ll give it some thought.”
SCP-682 said.
“You’ve been very helpful for a disgusting
human, so for the time being, I will permit
you to continue your meaningless existence.
And I guess that includes the rest of your
outpost.”
“Oh, that’s… well, thank you…
I…
thank you.”
The human stammered.
SCP-682 turned and began to walk back towards
The Heart of Water.
It intended to take its time with its choice,
since progress through the levels of the Backrooms
was no longer something that the reptile would
be pursuing with reckless abandon.
It heavily considered going back on its words
and slaughtering all the members of the major
explorer’s group in this outpost - as it
had done in all the other outposts.
But it was plain to see that a human trapped
in the Backrooms barely qualified as living,
because nothing could be worse than being
permanently stuck in the torturous abyss.
682 had no idea whether pure spite towards
them was what made sparing their lives so
compelling or something else had motivated
that decision, but regardless - the hard-to-destroy
reptile did not destroy the humans of level
23.
As it exited the base, the brave human that
had spoken to it called out:
“Wait, lizard!
I have to know: what are you?”
682 stopped and stared at the human.
“It’s just… we need to catalog you.
I’ve never seen anything else in the Backrooms
like you.”
682 breathed out.
It sounded almost like a surrender.
“I am Entity 682.”
After those words left its jaws, 682 wandered
away from the human until it was once again
sitting by The Heart of Water.
It didn’t think about the choice or the
gateway immediately.
For now, Entity 682 was peacefully reminiscing
back to the quality time it had spent with
Entity 7 Jerry in this pointless and nonsensical
place known as the Backrooms.
They would meet again.
That was the one thing 682 could be sure of.
Somehow, someway, they would meet again.
An indeterminate amount of time later, over
24 levels away from the reptile in the Frontrooms
– the reality which it had no-clipped out
of so many days and weeks ago, the researchers
of the SCP Foundation had gathered together
and were celebrating an unforeseen event.
Almost all of them had long since given up
hope that it could ever happen.
And yet, here they were, standing before the
05 Council and all the illustrious scientists
and soldiers that had worked to make this
day a reality.
Everyone watched in total amazement as the
heads of the Foundation declared the keter-class
SCP-682 “hard to destroy reptile” permanently
neutralized.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?”
and “SCP-682 Slaughters Through the Backrooms”
for more of 682’s journey through the Backrooms!